When you imagine the robots of the future
what do you picture?
Humanoids made of steel?
Massive metal monsters?
Turns out, they might be a little squishier.
If you haven’t noticed, evolution of biological
life has done a pretty good job at making
things perfectly equipped to interact with
our world.
And now, robotics is starting to follow suit,
in an emerging field called soft robotics.
You’ve probably seen this little guy from
MIT swimming through your social media timelines.
Look at him go!
This autonomous fishbot can swim right alongside
marine life, giving biologists a whole new
way to observe this ecosystem.
And there’s other tech helping scientists
study the ocean, like this underwater microphone
aboard the Seeker Vessel!
Long distance swimmer Ben Lecomte and crew
are on an expedition to gather data to raise
awareness about ocean health.
Their hydrophone records the secret sounds
of the deep.
Hydrophones and soft robots could be important
conservation tools in the future, because
they’re uniquely suited to work with their
environment.
And these bots in particular draw inspiration
from nature for their designs.
But before I get into all that, let’s tackle
how these squishy bots actually work in the
first place.
The main characteristic of a soft robot is
that, well, it’s soft.
Instead of traditional materials, the body
is constructed out of rubber, polymers, and
sometimes even fabric.
But it’s harder to adapt the components
that make the bot move, like the actuators
- These have to be radically rethought for
soft bots, since traditional robots tend to
use electric motors that are difficult to
downsize.
So, instead some use hydraulics or pneumatics
to push air or water through the soft body
parts in a way that creates predictable motion.
Others use shape memory alloys that change
shape when exposed to heat, so when a limb
is heated, it will unfurl or coil up in a
particular way.
Some researchers are even looking into replacing
actuators with soft, LIVING MUSCLES, which
is [WHOA], and, a whole video of its own.
When it comes to the power source, some of
these guys- like our friendly robo fish - rely
on small lithium ion batteries.
But there’s also a lot of experimentation
in this part of the field - from hydrogel
batteries (which we’ve covered on the channel
before) to ditching batteries all together
and using chemical energy from hydrocarbons.
But, soft robotics still has some limitations.
Many robots still require tethers to electrical
or pneumatic devices because we haven’t
figured out how to integrate these onboard
the robot, just yet.
That hasn't stopped engineers from tinkering
with new robots, and there are some really
cool ones in action!
One such example is the octopus robot from
BioRobotics.
Inspired by the squishy but strong nature
of octopus tentacles, This robot uses synthetic
arms that rely on shape memory alloys to grasp,
and even crawl- allowing the robot to travel
underwater.
Octopuses have also inspired gripping robots,like
this one from Harvard- that can gently pick
up marine life from the ocean floor so biologists
can study them.
What makes all of these robots so promising
is the way they easily adapt to new tasks
and environments, unlike traditional robots
that would need to be frequently modified
or reprogrammed.
This also means they have a ton of applications.
They could one day be used in rescue missions
that require squeezing through small spaces
and traversing over rugged terrain.
Or these soft, biocompatible robots could
be used inside your body for medical diagnosis
& treatment.
To be honest, I’m kind of surprised it’s
taken us this long to start making soft robots.
I mean when you look at animals--which are
debatably the best examples we have for adapting
to new environments -- they’re pretty much
all soft!
Humans ourselves are less than 15% rigid material!
But, I suppose, biological evolution did take
millions of years, and to be fair, robot evolution
has only just begun.
To stay up to date with the latest soft robot
updates, subscribe!
And to check out the crazy sounds Ben and
his crew recorded with their hydrophone- watch
their latest episode here.
This data will help us learn about our largest
ocean’s marine life AND help us to protect
it!
Can’t get much cooler than that.
Thanks for watching.